[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
le sais tu ce loisir ne fait pas le
pourrai vous propose plein d'idées
sorties
le sommaire de ce jeudi de mai en cette
période de vacances scolaires nos jeunes
trappistes ont découvert les médias au
travers d'un atelier de l'espace jeunes
anatole france
nous avons assisté à leur émission radio
il sera avec nous en plateau le musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye anime son exposition consacrée à
henri ii des parcours interactif à
découvrir jusqu'au 5 mai le musée de
l'homme de la mythique place du
trocadéro à paris consacre une
exposition à la peau en partenariat avec
l'oréal explique le plus grand organe
l'être humain nous rentrerons dans notre
épiderme en fin d'émission le service
jeunesse de la ville de trappes organise
différentes activités à chaque période
de vacances scolaires cette semaine les
trappistes ont découvert les médias avec
calypso gagner nous avons suivi leurs
webradio décisions importantes ce
jour-là à l'espace jeunes anatole-france
de la ville de trappes
le choix du nom de leur émission de
radio ce sera donc trappe radio au
programme une interview du maire adjoint
à la jeunesse et aux sports à l'aide
d'un micro trottoir réalisé la veille
l'intérêt c'est vraiment de leur dire
comment pourra intéresser un auditeur et
après ils ont un petit peu le champ
libre pour faire ce qu'ils veulent là
dessus et des chroniques sur les thèmes
de leur choix qu'ils préparent
minutieusement un fait des recherches et
après et après il ya des personnes qui
écrit les personnes qui cherchent on
s'est dit avec tout ce qui en ce moment
et tout ce qui se passe à la télé tout
ce qui se passe et où leur faire
découvrir ne pas rester juste sûr on
voit ce qui se passe à la télé on reste
bloqué sur ces images là leur dire
maintenant mais il ya autre chose et de
la préparation derrière il ya des
recherches d'un faux neuf jeunes âgés de
13 à 16 ans participent à cet atelier
découverte des médias derniers tests
sont comme des pros avant la grande
interview pour laquelle ils ont choisi
leur thème l'évolution numérique et
l'égalité femmes hommes
j'ai une deuxième question qui me tient
à coeur c'est qu'est-ce qui est mis en
place à trappes pour lutter contre
l'inégalité enfin des thématiques les
explore ensuite en chronique critique de
livres d'horreur éléments d'information
sur un duo de rap français réflexion sur
ce que l'on peut faire avec 500 euros et
même des billets engagé j'espère aussi
que dans quelques temps il y aura plus
de femmes qui ont des métiers plus
important est qu'ils ont qui aura une
femme présidente
je pense que cela se réalisera au fil du
temps attention messieurs les amarres
pourquoi ce thème parce qu'il tient à
coeur je trouve ça
important d'en parler j'ai parlé du
salaire des hommes et des femmes j'ai
parlé de ce que ce qui pourrait nous
faire pour changer cela
les voix des jeunes imposé radio trappe
dans la boîte alors munir d'un animateur
à l'espace jeunes anatole france ainsi
que steve albini lots la cud hébergeons
nous ont rejoints sur le plateau bonjour
bonjour alors vous venez de découvrir le
reportage
lola on t'envoie déclamer ta chronique
pleine de conviction comment tu l'as
vécu cette émission radio j'ai trouvé ça
très bien j'ai bien aimé ça ça nous fait
découvrir plein de choses
c'était super super intéressant à faire
et comment tu l'as préparait ta
chronique
alors j'ai fait des recherches c'est un
thème qui m'est venue directement
donc franchement c'est m'est venue
direct et après j'ai fait quelques
recherches et j'ai aussi utilisé ce que
je savais déjà
on l'a vu il ya eu cette émission c'est
eh ben vous avez découvert d'autres
choses aussi durant la semaine sur le
sport également dans ce soir la défaite
du paris saint germain contre rennes ça
c'est la chronique et toi tu as écrit
voilà avec mon frère vous avez fait quoi
et dont vous avez fait un micro trottoir
et aujourd'hui vous êtes à l'effet 3d
est ce ce soir qu'est-ce que vous avez
là bas bah en fait on a vu tout ok
montage de son son image leur matériel
aussi très très important très très
comment dire en matière très
impressionnant ouest mais voilà c'était
impressionnant
alors vous dire comment c'est venu cette
idée à l'espace jeunes anatole france de
faire une semaine sur les médias comme
ça on va on en parle et on a entre
animateurs avant chaque période de
vacances on réfléchit à des mini stages
qu'on pourrait créer pour les jeunes
voir ce qu'on pourrait faire pour les
attirer plus uniquement sur certains
sujets sans faire des débats avec une
personne devient leur parler pendant
trois heures quelque chose comme ça on
s'est dit que c'était important que ça
pouvait le faire en faisant comme ça on
est en plus le mec très ludique en
n'allant pas eux mêmes faire les
questions posées les questions et c'est
de là avec mon collègue marc hamon s'est
dit bah tiens on va monter tout ça
pendant ces vacances là et on va voir
comment ça marche
donc là les jeunes on a peut-être envie
de continuer faire trappe radio plus
souvent oui franchement oui ça m'a donné
envie d'en faire plus oui mounir pour
vous continuerez tête
bah oui pourquoi pas après
moi c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse
on en a parlé avec un l'élu à la
jeunesse et aux sports pourquoi pas
essayer de on a on a de quoi faire on aa
marmite fm à trappes
donc pourquoi pas essayer de créer une
chronique et puis de poser quelque chose
vraiment un marmite et fait mal et
souvent et faire un atelier à l'année il
ya un indien qui existent mais essayez
de peut-être le pousser un peu plus
crois pas si on part un peu plus
généralement après l'espace jeunes là il
y avait mon avis un atelier spécifique
mais via procès plein d'autres activités
ah oui à plein de choses il ya là il ya
eu un stage de sport les vacances juste
avant il ya eu un stage mécanique où il
apprenait plein de choses bien sûr les
moteurs sur elle même les vélos et tout
ça il ya eu un stage citoyenneté où les
jeunes ont passé leur ps1 leur brevet de
secourisme
il ya vraiment plein de choses qui sont
mises en place puis après les et elles
ne sont pas je sais pas juste les
animateurs s'il ya des jeunes qui sont
intéressés par faire quelque chose ils
peuvent venir nous voir on monte un
projet avec eux et en francs et apprend
créer un truc pour une semaine peut-être
l'été voilà justement là on est dans
l'émission loisirs c'est quoi vos
loisirs à vous moi c'est le théâtre et
je fais un peu sport avec le collège moi
c'est du judo et du sport avec lieu au
collège avec tout le monde quoi montrer
là on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
remercie tous les trois d'être venu sur
le plateau
merci à vous de nous avoir buté merci
mounir je crois qu on vous retrouve
prochainement dans le 7-8 humour le life
et badou contre peut-être plus tard
parmi mes collègues ne sais pas
maintenant on va parler cinéma est-ce
que vous avez vu le dernier à wengen
oui moi j'ai entendu parler bah oui
parce que c'est un énorme succès il
réalise même le meilleur démarrage de
l'histoire sur le territoire nord
américain
c'est lors de vos rendez vous dans les
salles par manou par aldo
[Musique]
à l'espace philippe noiret dans la ville
de les clayes-sous-bois nous avons des
films pour les enfants pour les vacances
comme royal corgis la princesse des
glaces dumbo ou encore le parc des
merveilles
nous avons également des films plus pour
les grands comme santiago italia ou bien
victor et célia et cela mon mariage le
plus fort de tout ça assez avengers que
nous attendions tous le 22e opus de la
saga univers du l'univers
cinématographique de marvel 10 11 ans de
films le dernier opus nous présente nos
super héros dans leurs sentiments les
plus humains qu'ils soient possibles et
clôture du coup sûr une super saga donc
ton peut voir le thanos qui a conquis le
monde avec cgem et les nos super héros
reviennent avec iron man black widow
avec antoine les gardiens de la galaxie
tous vont s'allier contre thanos pour
récupérer la main des gènes on revient
du coup en arrière dans les précédents
opus pour voir comment affronter thanos
et récupérer les gemmes afin qu' il
puisse sauver le monde
[Musique]
c'est un rendez vous incontournable de
la bergerie nationale le marché fermier
de paris fernier du 3 au 5 mai une
centaine de producteurs vous proposent
leurs produits de la mort biffle est à
la crêpe à l'oeuf d'autruche et bien sûr
des animations avec les animaux de la
ferme pour les enfants ce week-end des 4
et 5 mai versailles par le jardin esprit
jardin rassemble chaque année plus de
20000 visiteurs
plus de 80 exposants autour de l'art du
jardin avec également un spectacle des
visites et des ateliers
l'événement promet une plus grande
ampleur il vous relate première vénale
d'architecturé de paysage de la région
ile-de-france et de versailles direction
saint germain en laye le musée
d'archéologie nationale consacre une
exposition à henry 2 le souverain il ya
500 ans ou 100 du château une première
qui rassemble une centaine d'oeuvres
pour faire vivre pleinement cette
exposition à son public le musée
organise des parcours interactif des
activités qui s'ajoutent aux visites
musicales le rendez vous originalité du
musée tous les premiers week-ends du
mois le samedi le secret du roi d'un
jour denim que l'on mène à plusieurs qui
permet de découvrir progressivement à la
vie le quotidien d'henri ii et de sa
famille et une visite aussi sur la mode
souris 2 qui était particulièrement
somptueuse à l'époque le parcours le
secret du roi est ouvert
à tous les publics avait pu se faire en
famille à partir de 7 ans et les visites
sur la mode
elles sont aussi ouvertes à tous les
publics parce que justement c'est une
approche qui est un peu singulière un
peu atypique nous avons la chance
d'avoir des peintures à l'exceptionnel
et qui rendent compte justement de la
qualité et du faste de l'époque
plusieurs rendez vous sportif alors pas
du judo mais du football surtout dans le
championnat de national troyes
versailles recevra l'équipe des gobelins
dans ce samedi 4 mai au stade mont boron
victoire impérative pour les joueurs de
la cité royale ils sont actuellement
dans le top 5 du classement leur
objectif de début de saison mais ce
championnat est très serré chaque point
compte
on poursuit à trappes pour la 18e
journée du championnat de régionale 3
l'étoile sportive reçoit aubergenville
ce dimanche 5 mai à 15 heures au stade
gilbert chant sac les trappistes doivent
absolument l'emporter pour conserver
leurs chances de terminer premier de
championnat si vous voulez les soutenir
l'entrée est libre
direction paris pour explorer notre peau
[Musique]
notre peau ps3 à 100 kg chez un adulte
soit deux fois plus qu'un cerveau le
musée de l'homme consacre une exposition
à cet organe aux multiples surprises
reportage de maylis kar'ouest nos
confrères via grand paris infiltrez vous
dans votre épiderme pour comprendre
comment fonctionne votre peau
cet organe vital qui pèse deux fois plus
qu'un cerveau est composée de 70 % d'eau
ici on découvre comment se régénère les
cellules de notre peau
en 30 jours notre peau régénère
complètement
on va comprendre la structure de la peau
les capteurs la couleur les microbes qui
vit sur la peau bref on va se
familiariser avec l'organe qui nous sert
de correspondance avec l'extérieur et
puis dans une deuxième partie on va
comprendre comment la peau peut être
cultivée pour réparer les gens mais
aussi pour tester des cosmétiques sans
recourir à l'expérimentation animale et
en travaillant sur une peau humaine de
laboratoire une exposition interactive
avec des ateliers pour comprendre les
terminaisons nerveuses qui détermine les
brûlures ou les piqûres ou encore
connaître un monde de bactéries présents
sur notre peau cet atelier ici permet
même de mesurer la pigmentation de votre
peau grâce à des capteurs qui compare la
couleur de votre visage à une base de
données
on a une couleur de peau foncée pour se
protéger des ultraviolets quand l'homme
moderne est allé à la conquête des
climats froids il sait dépigmenter pour
que les ultraviolets puisse traverser la
peau on voit que la colonisation vers
les zones peu ensoleillé a conduit les
gens à devenir plus blanc on peut dire
que les blancs sont des noirs des
colonies donc ça c'est le processus qui
explique les couleurs de peau dans
l'humanité actuelle c'est la corrélation
entre le milieu de vie et l'adéquation
violée il aura fallu quarante ans de
recherches pour reproduire et in vitro
les fonctions physiologiques que cet
organe une exposition qui permet de
mieux se sentir dans sa peau à découvrir
jusqu'au 3 juin et c'est la fin de votre
7,8 loisirs merci nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles idées sorties
m
[Musique]
ouais
oh
[Musique]